car audio call fouquet sécrétaire
national du parti de gauche et
spécialiste de l'amérique latine
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors on l'a vu comment expliquer
ces sondages très favorables
agr bolzan euros alors que le pays a
dépassé les 85 mille morts alors il a
alors effectivement il a une gestion
très très théâtral de cette de cette
crise
alors comment comment l'expliquer il ya
plusieurs raisons la première il est
dans un contexte très particulier il
faut pas oublier que bolton arrow est
arrivé au pouvoir grâce à un système
particulier où la justice politique
s'est occupé de la principale élections
en compagnie des des différents médias
quand je parle de la principale
élections du brésil c'est celle de
l'élection présidentielle donc il est
dans un contexte particulier mais en
même temps il faut pas oublier que que
les sondages sont sont temporaires et
que l'élection brésilienne et dans deux
ans en tout cas en ce qui concerne les
allées présidentielle et du coup d'ici à
deux ans il y a encore beaucoup de
choses et notamment la crise économique
qui vient souvent après cette crise
sanitaire auquel les brésiliens n'ont
pas encore je dirais eu à subir de com
comme d'autres pays commencent à le
subir effectivement là c'est une
véritable c'est une véritable politique
théâtrale que qui essayent de cacher on
va dire la totale le l'incohérence le
déconfit en tout cas la situation
totalement chaotique de la gestion de
cette crise au brésil
c'est assez paradoxal à des centaines de
voisins sont sortis dans les rues de
brasilia pour soutenir ball solaro après
sa contamination
le président brésilien semble avoir une
base d'électeurs acquise à sa cause
comment comment on explique cette
ferveur autour du président écoutez je
je je pense ce goûter où je regarde plus
l'aspect politique sur sur deux de
bolton euros effectivement il ya des
moment qu' il ya des moments de
l'histoire du brésil qui sont qui sont
assez sombres sur différents points on
peut pas se l'expliquer d'une façon on
va dire très très rapide ce qui est sûr
c'est que il profite d'un contexte
particulier qui est celui de son
élection présidentielle et qui est que
c'est le gestionnaire on va dire de 7,2
de cette crise et je le rappelle une
fois de plus c'est une gestion très
chaotique parce que si on rentre un peu
plus dans les dans les détails et qu'on
est un peu plus dans les villes c'est on
va dire une une multitude de politiques
différentes qui ont été mises en place
en fonction des en fonction des villes
en fonction des en fonction des
différentes provinces c'est un peu comme
avoir un code de la route différenciées
en fonction des villes et en fonction
des régions ici en france vous voyez
c'est une situation qui donne un
contexte assez particulier alors
effectivement il aura toujours des
départissant de sa de sa cause qui est
une cause très
test il les a annoncé de façon théâtrale
avoir derrière qu'est ce qu'il y a qu
est-ce qu il ya d être derrière tout ça
c'est avant tout moi ce que je regarde
c'est les chiffres au niveau du brésil
qui on est et qui ont été rappelés ces
prêts dont on se dirige doucement vers
l'est vers les 100000 mans il ya plus de
2 millions de contaminés derrière tout
ça c'est une
c'est une gestion qui qui cache beaucoup
de choses vous avez d'un côté la forêt
amazonienne qui continue justement à
ceux à être transformés à être détruite
à à venir à 2 à de nouvelles crises et
de l'autre côté vous avez une
je dirais une image qui est orienté dans
tout l'est dans tous les médias qui est
celle du du président salvateur du
sauveur de la nation
donc pour le moment en tout cas on peut
voir que sur certains sondages ça marche
mais je suis pas sûr que à moyen ou long
terme ceci sera très efficace
merci beaucoup claudio caf au caire
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
national du parti de gauche et
spécialiste de l'amérique latine